you'll share the recipe share the recipe
this is amazing Rani's random milk
hey guys it's Inka as you all know I
make a lot of food videos here at
BuzzFeed and I love the concept of viral
foods but I'm also thinking you know
sometimes I'm scrolling through my
Instagram feed and I just see certain
food items blow up out of nowhere
rainbow bagels or like unicorn ice cream
I find it fascinating and I really want
to figure out you know how do these food
items become viral on the internet
recently Ben and Andrew from Bova guys
reached out to me and asked if I wanted
to make a custom boba drink with them I
love boobity and I think this is a
really cool opportunity for me to see if
I can make my drink go viral so let's go
to Bobo guys so I finally made it out
here to the bubble guys Canal Street
Market location as you can see I am
holding a lot of stuff in my hands these
are three of my favorite childhood
drinks there's chrysanthemum tea I drank
this like all the time Milo which is
like a classic breakfast drink and then
there's a Korean banana milk I only go
to drink this though when I got really
good grades so this is really special to
me you think we can make something out
of this I think there's a hit in there
what we usually do is we'll make like a
base recipe and then we can see where
they go let's try them all you know all
right so I guess we have a lot of
experimenting to do let's do it awesome
[Music]
we've made all three of the drinks all
three of them are incredible but I
really think the Korean banana milk
drink is my favorite I mean I love
bananas but also I think this has the
potential to go viral the most prevalent
in Korean culture but it's also such a
popular flavor and we have something
here we definitely think it's something
that we can have in almost any boba shop
cafe across the world I think that was
our first shot I mean it's pretty good
but we should probably keep refining
this because right now it's kind of
simple I know who can take it to the
next level he's obsessed with banana
milk he could probably help us take this
to the next level all right I'm excited
let them elevate this even more so I
heard chowin been talk to you about
Korean banana milk I'm super super
stoked that they're doing a drink and
you guys are featuring this because it
really is much healthy I am dead serious
take a shot of that
I already do inject that stuff for my
bloodstream
it's my fuel I heard you guys made a
version of okay now I don't know if I
could give you the version that we made
just try this it's it's good it's not
Korean banana milk though I think it's
missing a couple things so hopefully we
can cut out like that's where I want it
bring it to the Korean banana level we
start with bananas riper the better some
coconut cream just to kind of give it
that nice like mouthfeel I like brown
sugar cuz it kind of rounds it out one
thing that I kind of noticed from your
drink it was it wasn't I don't think was
balanced it was just kind of like banana
and then like stream I think some sort
of acid few drops of lemon juice might
really help out it's kind of like how
you put salt in there exactly
together once you cook it down it
becomes this nice beautiful Jam kind of
marmalade consistency banana this is the
base to kind of all the drinks so use
this and to you know add milk whatnot
and then this would be kind of a good
start to a true Korean banana mo why
don't you try it oh yeah Jam was good by
itself but with milk it's like perfect
mmm that's that's Korean banana vote do
convenience mean been an enjoy to try
this come on what I'm good at enjoy
please Wow our job is to make everything
scale I think we could bring this to a
thousands of people now good good
synchronize in Tom though I had a few
days before the drink was to be launched
and so I started doing some research
into the different ways that we could
kick this off and one of the ways I
found was actually influenced in
marketing which is a very common way to
spread the word nowadays and so I
started texting a lot of my friends to
see if they'd be down to help out
assuming they liked the drink and a lot
of them did and then a day or two before
the drink was to be launched so you
started posting their stories
[Music]
[Music]
bow-bow guys also posted about it on
their official account and I also posted
about it on my Instagram then we go to
the cool part because once these went up
people started talking about it word
started spreading and that's when the
comments start rolling in I went to bowl
guys for the first time I swear there
were four people in front of me and they
told me that's the reason they went
there just to try the drink
that's insane so we could already see
signs of people being excited about it
and there were lines like even across
the country and while all of this is
happening I'm also thinking what if I
could get some numbers in here and so I
looked up Korean banana milk on Google
Trends and I could actually see a
significant increase in search results
for it which was so incredible I have
some super exciting news Ben told me
that the drink 1000 of them have been
sold in only four days only four days
and they were all week days so that's
super exciting I think we're on the
right track here and just to amp it up
even more I decided to really lean into
food photography with the help of my
friend Ben
let's hope we get the shot we want
[Music]
[Music]
we are now in the middle of the street
fence right here we're gonna take a
couple of shots and see what it looks
like
[Music]
trying another shot
[Music]
get this shine
and then a week later been posted the
photos we took on his food Instagram and
the comments were just so positive it
reminded people of their childhood and
people wanted to try it
bow-bow guys also reposted the photos
with really really similar results in
the comment sections and we could really
see that interest growing organically
but the best part of it all was probably
having my favorite Korean hip hop group
epic high try the drink and that's about
it I can't say the drink has gone mega
viral or anything but it's been an
incredible journey and it's really cool
being able to see people try something
that I had a part in creating and also
being able to see people connect to it
if you haven't tried the drink yet
definitely go try it out and tell me
what you think in the comments below
[Music]